So, how did the system know that
the Maps app could handle this intent?
The activity within the Maps app
included an intent filter,
like this one, within its manifest entry.
It indicates that the Maps app
is capable of performing
this view action on all data
which has a geo scheme.
You can use intent filters
for your activities to define
the actions they're capable
of performing, and optionally,
the kind of data that
they can perform it on.
So when you use
an implicit intent to address
or request to start an activity,
much like you did with Catherine
and the openweathermap.org link,
Android resolves this request
by checking the intent filters
of every activity that's installed
on the device until it finds
the best possible match.
If multiple activities match,
as in the case with the web URL,
the user is given a choice.